you are watching ColdFusion TV
hi welcome to another ColdFusion video
in my last video a few of you pointed
out that it was going to be the Chevy
bolt that could be the first
mass-produced electric car that wasn't
underpowered not the Tesla Model 3 and
you guys were right I'd actually
mistaken the Chevy bolt for another car
which is a hybrid called the Chevy Volt
so I ruled it out we don't have
Chevrolet over here in Australia we have
Holden instead which makes completely
different cars so sorry about that
I actually mix things up now with that
out of the way I just wanted to set the
record straight the point of this video
is to update my analysis on the advent
of electric cars for the masses with
Chevrolet getting involved everything
changes in essence the race for the
electric car involves an established
industry giant versus an innovative
startup there's actually a strange twist
to this emerging story but we'll get to
that later so grab the popcorn things
could get very interesting over the next
few years alright so let's take a look
at what's going on ladies and gentlemen
meet the 2017 Chevrolet bolt
evie the bold Evie is truly the first
Evie that cracks the code of long range
at an affordable price I have no doubt
that the auto industry will change more
in the next five to ten years than it
has in the last 50 let's look at the
specs we don't have much information or
we really have this the range and the
acceleration so for the Chevy bolt we
have 200 miles of range and just under 7
seconds for 0 to 100 kilometres an hour
or 0 to 60 miles now and for the Tesla
Model 3 we have 215 miles of range and
just under six seconds to accelerate
from zero to 100 kilometres an hour
it seems like the bolt has the jump on
the model 3 for production Chevy said
that the bolt will go into production
late this year so retail availability
might be 2017 production for the model 3
is much harder to call Tesla promises
production in late 2017 but there's
already been huge demand with over
270,000 pre-orders so the question is
can they deliver both companies have
established significantly different
brand reputations Tesla with the Model S
and Model X is seen as a luxury car
maker but they had to do this in order
to get to the mass-market phase the
Model S quickly became the car of choice
the types like Silicon Valley executives
and well-off tech enthusiasts the model
3 will benefit from this reputation
Chevy can boast many more years of
experience but in terms of brand this
experience might not necessarily work in
their favor this time around given
Chevy's broad-based appeal its
mainstream buyers may find it too early
to try an electric car regarding the
bolt as an early adopter model of what
I've heard and what I can gather most
people expect Chevy cars to be
affordable and not fancy that seems to
be their brand image
the big decider is price and there's
been a bit of confusion here because
most people think that the bolt is
actually cheaper than the model 3 but
it's actually the other way around when
you take into account government
incentives while the bolt will be
$30,000 with tax incentives factored in
according to Motor Trend the retail
price will be $37,000
musk has repeatedly said that the model
3 will be priced at $35,000 before
incentives and with incentives ranging
from 7,500 to 13,000 dollars depending
on which US state the price for the
Model 3 could be as low as $22,000 in
some US states this is the u.s. centred
view though we don't have any
information on how much it will cost in
other countries and frankly who knows
the CEO of Tesla Elon Musk doesn't see
the bolt as a competitor he is
previously talked about the desire for
electric cars to succeed no matter who
makes them this philosophy has led to
masks offering up Tesla's patents for
other companies to use in good faith in
essence more electric cars in the road
means more infrastructure for charging
on the go and also means the mainstream
will become more comfortable with them
if the bolt gains mass market acceptance
this actually helps the Model 3 are you
worried at all about GM beating you to
the market with this upcoming bolt due
out next year you know III think if GM
comes to market with a compelling
electric car that's great the goal of
Tesla from the beginning has been to
accelerate the advent of sustainable
transport so yeah I think if if GM or
any other company comes out with
compelling electric cars that's good for
the world and you know we were deployed
so why don't Chevrolet or any other car
company make an electric car earlier
well General Motors actually did just
this in 1996 as a response to the
California mandate the required
automakers to have zero emission
vehicles ready on the market by 1998 in
response GM rolled out the ev1 the first
mass-produced electric car of the modern
era it wasn't perfect and had a range of
only just fifty miles but it still did
receive a devout following and maybe
could have appealed to a wider
demographic with subsequent improvements
General Motors put its new EB 1 electric
car in the market today in California
and Arizona Channel 5 News reporter
Willis Anne Meyer has details for us in
this report it's smooth its quiet and it
can do 0 to 60 in 9 seconds without
polluting the environment this is the
ev1 GM's new all-electric car now
available to consumers customers are
already buying the ev1 constants
chestnut says she'll be using furs for
work
she's a realtor it also means that I
will never go to another gas station and
I've ever talked to another mechanic and
that's a lot of fun but all of this
didn't matter in the end because GM
lawyers were lobbying hard with other
manufacturers to get California to back
down on its requirement they succeeded
right around the time when the e V was
ready to hit the dealerships California
weakened its mandate relieving the legal
pressure on the automakers to offer zero
emission cars GM recalled the ev1 and
took them all out to the desert and
crush them ending the electric car as we
know it well until Tesla came along so
General Motors has gone full circle from
being the ones to destroy the electric
car all the way to possibly being the
first to sell them so pretty much at the
end of the video but I just wanted to
voice a couple of notes of my concern
there are some footnotes about the wider
economy that I should make right now
we're in a global deflation period
meaning that this less expandable wealth
for consumers to spend and this will
probably hurt the sales of both
companies in the United States
particularly there's also a subprime
auto loan bubble which could also be
dangerous for these companies if they
take part in
that so anyway all-in-all I think we're
witnessing a big change in the auto
industry and maybe even witnessing a
turning point in history a time where we
can look back and pinpoint the exact
moment when the electric car really
arrived and it's really a good thing
carbon monoxide which is released from
general auto vehicles is very poisonous
and even lethal at high concentrations
so if you're in a city having tens of
thousands of cars outputting this
chemical day after day all around you
can't be good for your health or the
environment so it's a good idea to
mitigate such things where we can anyway
that's the end of the video thanks for
watching I just thought I'd update my
views and set the record straight it's
going to be an interesting competition
between these two cars and we'll see
what happens in the future don't forget
to give this video a thumbs up if you
liked it and subscribe this has been -
go go you've been watching cold fusion
and I'll see you again soon for the next
video which could possibly be a
documentary on google's deepmind we'll
see how I go cheers guys have a good one
cold fusion it's me thinking
you